it's hard to express how excited all of  us at bethesda are to be here with you  today we're so grateful you're spending  the time and we know you've waited a  long time to finally see  starfield it's easily our most ambitious  game ever like our previous games it's  an epic role-playing game where you get  to be who you want and go where you want  but this time you'll be exploring space  so let's jump right in this is early in  the game as you arrive on the mysterious  moon of crete  [Music]  [Music]  um  [Music]  according to the scanners the abandoned  research facility is in this direction  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  my  [Music]  it would appear that pirates of the  crimson fleet are using the facility  hey there you  [Music]  opening  are  you're gonna pay for that  you